this was not what i'd imagined for my  life  i mean buying a family home yes but i'd  imagine buying it with a family  i hadn't imagined my gay best friend a  pregnant woman  a middle-aged nurse or a tradie  what what's wrong stupid  that's liz's ex-husband  i honestly didn't believe he wanted kids  but clearly he just didn't want them  with me  we're gonna be sneaking around like this  forever you don't know what people say  about us  she's old enough to be his mother  look who's disrupted zayn is my nephew  [Music]  i just got butterflies don't you want to  have baby to grow up with its father  for randoms  okay ready  [Music]  [Applause]  i think mum has delivered me the perfect  man there's still something between us  we've just found a new home for  ourselves and it is where i want to be  you